as you get closer and closer to dates
you know they they continue to find ways
to back away so for example in this and
this in these minutes what I've been
able to pick up is they there there was
you know even you know some lack of
deciding this in terms of the wage
pressures and some of the linkages
between the tightness of the labor
market the unemployment rate the jobless
claims and alike and whether that filter
students the type of wage inflation that
they need to see so that they're
confident over the medium term on the
inflation outlook so they're finding
ways to wiggle away from you know
pulling the trigger and cetera we think
the Fed will go this year you know
whether or not September I think is a
coin flip to me the most troubling issue
for the Fed recently has been this drop
in inflation expectations but at the end
of the day if the Fed goes in September
they go in October they go in December
we're still facing an environment which
the monetary regime is starting to
change the probability is still very
high that the Fed raises rates in
September although it was a really sound
like the statement itself with a lot of
openings to do whatever they needed to
do they're just edge themself a little
closer it's like putting their toe into
cold water they you know are continuing
to move to that point where they sort of
get into very gently lifting free it
just gently as possible and I think
there's really nothing new to me in in
these minutes although i think you know
markets were looking for some clear sign
but that's not going to give it their
stainless and we need a couple more
months they got one month of good
employment we need to know inflation
stabilizing well the inflation was weak
today but core inflation is what does
look stable and they've been heartened
by that so I think these minutes don't
tell me you should bet against September
I think September's right on the table
you know three weeks ago they thought it
was a good chance but not a certainty
that they would raise rates in September
and clearly the news since then would
push a little bit away from that of you
know but not by a huge amount so I
suppose I'd still bet although it's
getting pretty close that they would
start to raise rates in September